thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show we give you the
same financial adviser grandmother would
only we keep our teeth in it is a free
call at Triple Eight 8 to 5 5 2 to 5 you
jump in and we'll talk about your life
we're talking with Linda in San Antonio
Texas and she was telling me about her
suddenly talked about that hello hello
hello hi Linda hi I'm talking with you
about her your honor let me stop just
second we were we were you were telling
me about your son-in-law and daughter no
marriage license living with a group of
people very kind and very giving but
give so much that they live off of
government assistance and now you have a
grandchild on the way and that's a fair
summary of what you told me so far yes
sir and we broach the subject about
setting up a savings account for the
educational needs of our grandson they
don't want to do that that's not within
the I don't know parameters of their
community settings I know they have no
will I doubt they have life insurance or
retirement so we would like some advice
from you on how to approach them
biblically uh in working your plan okay
and do we talk to our just our daughter
or both of them okay um well I think
obviously the this is put a highlighter
the baby coming has put a highlighter on
the differences that you and I have with
the way they're living correct and so
really we're not just addressing if you
have this conversation you're not trying
to just address the the child only um
you know it's the whole situation
they're basically trying to be
modern-day hippies and live in a commune
is what you're saying and and somehow
they've gotten that some kind of twisted
toxic version of Scripture that allows
them to think that that's all okay I
don't think you're going to talk them
out of it I think you would have a long
time ago if you could have
um I don't think that's going to change
and if any money you put in this child's
name is in danger of being used by the
commune at some point maybe by the time
the child is 18 is a child may be
brainwashed into this stuff by then so
right we're setting up a college savings
account under our name yeah we're it's
not really a college savings account
you're just having an investment that
you're doing and you've got it earmarked
for for this Bobby boy and you can tell
him when he's growing up grandpa and
granny have a college account over here
if you're going to go to college and
then if he comes knocking on the door
wants to go to college it's under your
rules because it's your money your money
not under mom and dad's rules and no
we're not supporting the commune that
lives off of welfare and you know we're
just not that's not what this moneys for
this is for you son and this is your
conversation with him when he's 18 and
so I'm going to save money and build
wealth period and then just uh you know
as the child grows just to have the
conversation with him that you have
money set aside for his college and just
just tell them you know you can tell
them we have money over here and it's
earmarked for his college if he ever
wants to go and and you know it's not
going to be in your name it's not going
to be in his name so it doesn't violate
your okay with us setting up an account
yeah they're fine with that it just
doesn't violate the rules of the commune
because if it goes into their name they
have to share it with their hippie
friends that's what it comes down to
right right and so we're not doing that
and and so you lay all of that out and I
think biblically you've done all you can
do I mean you just got a kid that's off
the ranch here and I mean it's sad I'm
sorry it's it's hurtful to you I'm sure
you've been very kind very mecco you've
been very kind and very diplomatic but
it's painful to watch your grown
children do stupid stuff that brings
harm to them and so that it's hard it's
very very hard to stand back and watch
that but you don't have a choice they're
adults I get to do what they want to do
and you've been able to maintain
relationship although I'm sure it's
somewhat strained at times right but I
would just maintain relationship and
then just love this grandbaby and um you
know you your have a little happy
you don't see anything biblically that
we can approach them and maybe get to
see our son-in-law see the light III
don't think he wants to listen anybody I
think he's a cult leader it's what
you've described and he's very
controlling yes
and I mean not not a full-on cult leader
but I mean he's got the aspects of it
he's very controlling he's got all of
these people dancing on the industry and
he does it all through you know the
social justice movement or whatever he's
doing but um but he sees he's got a game
running here and he's not going to
listen to anybody until something blows
up now something blows up when they come
to you for help
now you have the right to speak into it
I do not give people money that will not
take my advice anyone on the planet
right and you know and we're thinking of
setting up a trust in the end with our
whatever monies will be left yeah yeah
for the baby and and but these kids are
not the trustees that you set up a
separate trust with somebody that's got
it that that's got your value system and
they're going to implement the trust and
and if your grandkids follow the same
path they don't get the benefit of the
trust either because you're going to be
financing their craziness just like if
you start pouring money into this
commune right correct so I'm so sorry
it's a harsh it's a hard thing to face
and it's really hard to stand back and
watch it but I think it sounds like
you've been very gentle but very firm
all along is the way you've it's it's
the spirit you've portrayed I didn't
hear meanness or anger frustration but I
didn't hear meanness or anger and I
didn't hear you you know
flailing around and trying to fix them
because you probably can't you know well
I think it sound like you guys are very
healthy and how you're approaching is
what it sounds like to me so I just keep
the wealth and your name set up a trust
separate trustee make the terms of trust
very clear that the people receiving
benefits of the trust have to be
operating on a value system that's X Y &
Z and that is not in line with their
parents at this point so very sad very
sad and you probably ought to let cult
leader and your daughter know that your
leaving them any money when you die
they're not getting any money because
you're not going to have it dispersed
through the commune and so because we
don't think that's a but we don't think
you're being good stewards and so we're
not we feel as good stewards we can't
pass the responsibility of managing
God's money on to you but it will there
will be a trust set up for junior and
for the kiddo assuming the kiddo doesn't
follow the same path and that that's you
know my kids have the same rules by the
way Linda so I would pick up the book
let me send you two books I'm going to
send you to book Henry clouds book
boundaries which is an excellent book on
the subject and it sounds like you've
had pretty healthy boundaries and you
sounds like you've done a very admirable
job in this messed-up deal and then I'm
going to send you a copy of our book the
legacy journey which is our book about
wealth from a Christian perspective and
there's a lot in there about the kinds
of things we're talking about with
inheritance and and your obligation to
leave money to your kids is not there if
they're not being wise stewards and
because our obligation is to God to
manage his money his ways and to leave
it to someone whether their relative or
not that's not going to do that would be
inconsistent with that so I'm sorry
sorry you're facing that hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you